you guys were that makes a lot of sense
when you put it like that yeah exactly
that's just argument that's that's what
I'm here to do you know so I'm assuming
you guys were in athe years about 5
minutes now
you're brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £1 is used to buy food
or bricks or whatever to help the people
in Gaza but then just imagine this
amazing D that you want to do but we
turn it into a money-making machine how
the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of true name
Frankie Frankie y Frankie and Holly and
Holly yes I'm assuming you guys are a
couple yeah yeah yeah when you plan
getting married maybe
around maybe 25 25 sure you need to
propose yeah can she she wants you to
propose I'm joking okay guys so Frankie
you said that you um you're both atheist
yeah yeah yeah I don't really believe in
anything okay all right okay so um what
evidence would you require to believe in
God is there anything specific that
you're looking for I or have you ever
had any signs or what is it that
stopping you from believing God both you
I need like sign of
uh just something to answer my prayers
some sort of sign of his pre yeah okay
so I'll bring I'll just make there's a
couple arguments I usually use depends
who I'm talking to but I'll simplify a
bit for you yeah so do you have a mobile
phone yeah okay do you mind getting out
yeah sure yeah okay so all right you've
got a phone okay you would agree that
this phone has design yep okay you agree
that it has a shape a specific shape
yeah it does and does it have a purpose
yeah it's got purpose when okay good
yeah exactly yeah yeah calling your
girlfriend you know make sure you pick
up you know if she wants to pick up yeah
okay good so have you gone to the
factory to see this being assembled no
okay but you've come to the conclusion
by using your rational faculties that by
the design the shape the purpose that it
has a designer yeah correct okay would
you say you as a human being are comp
more complex in design or your mobile
phone yeah yeah yeah of course it's
human beings yeah the human eye yes the
way you function your heart your lung
comple so much more complex so my
argument is the following if we look at
a phone we haven't gone to the factory
we haven't seen seen it get made but we
come to the conclusion that he has
design he has a pattern it's got a
specific shape he has a purpose so my
argument is the following if you we as
human beings are more far complex in
design surely The Logical conclusion we
can come to is that we have to have a
Creator it wouldn't make sense because
my microphone my t-shirt my socks even
my socks have a purpose yeah even they
can be quite smelly at times but that's
a different issue yeah the point is what
the socks my socks has a specific shape
I know when I look at my socks it
doesn't belong on my head or my hand I
know where it belongs so we have has a
purpose so my argument is that
everything that we have from your hat to
your earrings to your shirt Everything
has a purpose it has a design which
means somebody made it now just because
we don't see God or the creator doesn't
mean he doesn't exist so that's the
argument that I would say that would
prove that it requires us as human
beings to have a creator that created us
yeah so I don't know if that's
convincing but that's one of my
arguments that I would say logically
following if we're going to be
consistent all these things that are
made around us has that and like for
example we have arguments say this is a
Quran imagine any other book there's
information yes yeah so information
requires intelligence am I right y yes
so when we open any book it might not be
the Quran it can be any book for that
matter Harry Potter you open it and
there's a story so you know very well
that somebody intended to write that
okay good so now we you know that we are
made from DNA DNA has information
information requires intelligence so a
single strand of DNA has more
information than every single book on
this Earth so my argument is that if
there's information in that DNA it
requires intelligence yeah and that
intelligence has to be God Almighty
creator that created us that's my
argument to prove that God exists yeah
that's a good point it's a good point
yes so so so to us is that now we have
to ask the question is that okay if God
has created us why are we here what does
he want from us I mean did you choose
your name I didn't choose my name you
didn't choose your name did you choose
Ser exactly so this is where we say that
look I didn't choose my siblings I
didn't choose my mother and father I
didn't choose my name I didn't choose
the way I look yeah okay you didn't
choose to be handsome but you born like
that you
know so uh I'm sure she agrees with it
yes so there you go so the point is what
our purpose here has to be greater than
clubbing partying drinking smoking and
all these other things yeah so me I came
to Islam 11 years ago even though I look
like a Muslim I don't know what Muslim
looks like we have different shapes and
colors but I came to Islam 11 years ago
I used to live the typical Western
lifestyle but what happens is that your
you your soul is always looking for
something more that's why if you see our
Banner we have here it says are you
depressed anxious unhappy and there's a
verse in the Quran that says only in the
remembrance of God do hearts find peace
so I came to that realization about 14
years ago because I used to go clubbing
partying holidays chilling with my
friend doing all kinds of stuff but I
came to a point where it it's not
happiness I would go to the gym try to
look you know good but then there'll
always be someone else that's bigger
than me and it'll just make me unhappy
try to drive the best car somebody
driving something better so what happen
you get into this Perpetual cycle of
finding happiness and then you don't I
used to come to this very Sport and go
clubbing every week but I came to the
point where I was like I'm not happy why
because anything that you have in the
world like if I put both of you guys on
a train and you had everything that you
could ever want on a train there's two
questions you ask yourself who put me on
this train and where am I going besides
all of the things that you have so to us
is that we believe that it's it's
important for us to have a relationship
with God otherwise what happens is I see
this whole earth like a jungle yeah and
we are bound to harm oursel if we don't
follow what God Almighty has W for us so
for us we believe the Quran has been
sent by God Almighty we believe that
it's the same God that communicated with
Jesus Christians have Moses uh Judaism
so the purpose is what to fill a
fulfilled Life alcohol is one of the
biggest poisons on our planet on our
Earth yes it's one of the ACT leading
causes of breast cancer so the point is
what that our culture has taught us that
going to the Pine going to the pub and
having a pine it seem as a cultural
thing but it's harming us it's killing
us but why because Society has made it a
norm it's become something we've adopted
but it's killing us slowly so we believe
God Almighty has sent the Quran and it's
telling us to live by certain laws that
is best for us just like the phone that
you have the Creator who made that will
tell you don't throw your phone in fire
it's going to burn yeah so yeah in not I
don't want to give you guys a sermon but
yeah that's my argument why God exists
and um if you have any questions please
I'm feel free to
ask trying to think of a good question
if you do have any if you don't have any
it's fine my argument is just to prove
God exist I hope that I can't be I can't
be a questionable spot but that's fine
definitely that's fine I mean hopefully
that's something for provoking and I'll
give you guys a Quran and if you have
any questions I'm here every Friday
Sunday but you guys live up North but
yeah you can I give you guys a free qur
yeah yeah sure yeah sure you've already
got one yeah I've got one we give H hly
one thank you for your time that's all
right if if you have any questions let
me know if not I'll end the
I I I don't think I've got a question I
can't but so I would assume now Frankie
and Holly believes in some sort of a
Creator there there's definitely
something there's definitely something
out there definely you guys that makes a
lot of sense when you put it like that
yeah exactly that's just argument that's
that's what I'm here to do you know so
I'm assuming you guys were an atheist
about 5 minutes ago now you're more the
should we say at you believe there
something okay I'm leing I like that
that's that's a good one well thank you
thank for your time guys it was a
pleasure and my name is Ali da
um I'll will give you my YouTube channel
name the video might will be released
there so if you guys want to watch watch
yourselves a l i sorry I'll do
yeah yeah that's my channel
see yeah so yeah this video was a bit
heated one of the Tommy Robinson fans
came here it was a bit hostile yeah yeah
so one them might have like civilized
discussions of current affairs and all
that kind of stuff
yeah that's
awesome yeah yeah yeah I've been doing
it for about 11 years so yeah thank you
thank you very much thank you sister
Holly thanks for your time have a nice
time look out to yourself take care
byebye oh I mean that was a nice
discussion guys as you can see hello